Joining me today as a student and
activist and the director of high school
outreach for turning point USA,
Kyle [inaudible].
You have welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me on.
I'm excited to have you here.
We've met a couple times.
We've done some events together.
You are seemingly wise beyond your
years.
That's true.
All right,
let's get to it.
Well actually,
I mean in a weird way,
I guess you've been,
you've been sort of thrust into being
wise beyond your years.
You were obviously a survivor of the
parkland shooting.
Uh,
as you know,
I had your classmate calmer and Kasey,
I'm a couple of weeks ago and he kind of
laid out,
uh,
what happened to him that day and
subsequently everything that's happened.
So let's just start there because that's
kind of what put you on the map.
Okay.
I'll sort of preface it.
I don't like it.
I don't like to refer myself as a
survivor because I wasn't in the
building that was shot into and I think
that cheapens the pain and tragedy that
people who were in the building.
Uh,
so what happened with me that day,
it was fourth period.
Uh,
I was in,
I was in my fourth period Class A and
all of a sudden the alarms a ring.
So we go into the hallway and we're
walking out and we hear two,
like two little pops.
I don't know if two textbooks fell.
No fire,
fire works.
I really had no idea.
So we run back,
uh,
and I go and reach for,
for the,
uh,
the door to my classroom and the teacher
locked it.
So you go into a nearby room,
we get in there and we just hide for two
hours straight.
We just hear pops and ambulances.
I ended up.
So that was the freshman building and
the entire time we had no idea was going
on.
Uh,
and then all throughout the entire time
people,
uh,
immediately or just villainizing guns,
you know,
the second we got a second I got out of
the,
uh,
the closet that I was in,
kids were like,
we have to be an air fifteens
yeah,
let's not jump into the political
parties.
So it's like,
because it's interesting just listening
to you hear about that.
It's almost like the way you were
describing it almost sounds like you
weren't even there.
Like it's just like a story that you
were telling in a bizarre way.
So once.
Okay.
So all of this happens,
you find out now they're,
they're dead students.
I mean to do a friend killed.
So we get it.
We get out of the closet,
so takes us out.
They put their,
you know,
air fifteens in our faces,
take us out.
We have to put our hands on the person
in front of us walking outside and all
throughout this,
the most disgusting thing was every
single corner of the entire block
surrounding us was just filled with
media.
Cars was just like jam packed.
And what I saw there was that whenever
there was like someone crying or like a
moment of pain,
the media would just surround them and
encapsulate them.
Uh,
and I got home and I was really hoping
that this wouldn't be like a politicized
spectacle with like mass media jumping
the gun to everything.
Uh,
and sadly that was the case.
So when I was sitting there in shock,
seeing the numbers rise on the screens
for the death count,
it was like so insane to internalize
what had just occurred because like
everyone's always,
you know,
this will never happen to my school.
How could this happen to my school?
Uh,
and the sad reality is it can happen to
any school.
Like,
I mean,
stoneman Douglas was in the most
affluent,
low crime,
you know,
city I think in southern Florida.
And this happened at our school.
Did you know some of the kids that were
killed?
Yeah,
I knew one girl,
Helena.
She was in a class of my year back.
Yeah.
So what kind of time did you guys have
to grieve because that you were already
alluding to this,
but it was like,
it was as if the event happened,
the shooting happened,
and then it seemingly,
there was no grieving.
And then you guys were all over the
television.
You were all over twitter.
You at all political people using you
guys and all sorts of different ways.
Just tell me a little bit about just
kind of the grieving and trying to be
able to be.
How old are you now?
17.
You're 17.
Trying to be 16,
15,
16,
17 year old kids trying to just survive
something.
Unimaginably horrible.
Yeah.
I don't know how freshmen and sophomores
have managed to go through this.
Like I'm,
I'm at least a Jew.
I was a junior at the time,
so I,
I knew the school have a better in
somewhat of my self esteem,
a little more,
build up more and a little bit more
mature.
Uh,
but there was absolutely no time to
grieve whatsoever,
like a few days after the shooting.
They already buses up to Tallahassee
till,
you know,
kind of like push to like tug on the
emotional heartstrings of Republicans to
pass legislation that the otherwise
wouldn't have passed.
Who's they in that equation?
So there are some,
uh,
members,
in the Florida Senate,
uh,
that like personally like coordinated
buses.
I'm from Parkland to Tallahassee.
Yeah.
And what were your parents saying or the
friends,
you know,
parents.
Like,
it just seemed like the parents were
almost gone now,
now there is some of the parents that
are a little more high profile that I,
that I see,
but it was as if you guys were just like
taken.
That's what it felt like suddenly we're
seeing on CNN and town halls and I want
to talk a little bit about that,
but just like that you were just used
all over the place with not even having
a moment to just digest what happened.
So,
so here's how I don't think that
necessarily.
So,
so here's what I think will happen.
I think that the kids saw what happened.
They were shocked as they should be and
they decided tack,
like we said,
this can't happen to anyone else ever
again.
Let's do something.
You know what,
what really occurred is that the
mainstream media jumped,
jumped on this immediately,
uh,
and just like put it to like a national
scale and really used it to push a gun
control agenda.
And that's why I started speaking out
because I wanted to represent the other
side of stone douglas who doesn't
believe in gun control.
Yeah.
So just tell me a little bit about you
in high school before this.
Like we've jumped a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What,
what,
what was kyle?
Because you have like before this,
because I know you sort of as a
political beast now and like a wickedly
incisive twitter and like,
you know,
you've put on events that I've been part
of and I,
and you're incredibly organized and
connecting with great people and all
that stuff which is telling you about
the kid.
Before that,
I'll give you all the recap.
Give me the story of my life story.
Let's go.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so my parents came from Israel.
They immigrated here.
My Dad,
my mom served in the IDF.
They came here,
there's nothing worked their way up.
And then when I was,
when I was at home they taught me Hebrew
and English.
So we only spoke Hebrew at home so I'm
fluent Hebrew and they put me through
school and I was always the shortest kid
in the grade.
So I was like always like I was just
like,
even shorter than the shortest girl in
my grade.
I was like super short and like,
what was it like in like eighth grade?
I was four foot eight,
I was like legally it in eighth grade.
So I'll,
I got bullied a lot.
Like I try not to have a victim hood
mentality because I don't think it's
successful and I think you agree with me
on that.
Um,
so it was always bullied and I was
always,
I was always smart so that Kinda went
back on me a little bit,
but I was always put a lot and it built
up my self esteem.
In addition,
I was always like taking the hardest
classes.
My parents would always push me to take
the hardest classes possible.
Um,
so at Douglas,
before all this,
uh,
you know,
as someone who I had a good social life,
uh,
so I would basically,
I would go to school,
do my ap classes,
go home,
play video games,
so like 10,
10:00
PM,
start homework to like start homework,
you know,
and then finish it at 2:00
AM and then have like five hours of
sleep.
So that was my cycle was terrible.
But I was super addicted to video games
and then the shooting happens and just
turned my entire life upside down.
So it just completely changed me.
So at that moment,
you know,
I had to become much more mature.
I had,
I was living in the adult world,
you know,
I had responsibilities.
There are things that had to do,
you know,
I had to act a proper certain way and
uh,
did you have any particular political
beliefs before all this because you're
definitely in terms of at least the kids
or the young people that are public
about all of this now that have come out
of snowmen.
Douglas.
I mean,
you definitely are the one that seemed,
at least that I know of is,
is the furthest right that is sort of
embraced conservatism and all that did.
Is that where you were politically to
hear that?
They not about me.
My parents aren't political at all
whatsoever.
So all my political beliefs I have
developed myself and how I develop every
single political belief is just I look
at it straight from a rational,
logical point of view with no emotions
whatsoever.
I think you can guess I'm not an
emotional person,
so like I think with,
with legislative decisions,
you have to put a motion as far out of
it as possible.
You have to do policies that,
that actually solve the problem,
not just make you feel good.
So I'm really not a,
not for feel good policies.
You care about politics at all before
any of this or is this new?
Yeah,
I didn't care either.
The 2016 election I was,
I was somewhat into it after the
election I kind of didn't care as much,
but I was always somewhat of a second
amendment supporter.
Um,
yeah,
but when I,
when I started speaking out,
so it's really interesting.
When I started speaking out a,
it was like a tidal wave of opposition,
you know,
I had,
my school was against me.
Someone seemed like that,
you know,
all my peers were against me and I try
not to do a victim mentality.
I just want to paint the picture of how
it actually was.
And it seemed like the community,
the mainstream media and my friends,
you know,
it seemed like I was going against every
single opposition,
you know,
I was scared like this could,
this could have ruined my life,
but,
you know,
I believed in what I was doing and I
just power through it.
Uh,
and,
and just really,
I just stuck to my beliefs and didn't
let anyone tell me otherwise because,
you know,
when I was.
So when I was in Tallahassee,
uh,
when they were pushing Republican
legislators to enact gun control
legislation,
I said,
look,
gun control isn't going to solve the
problem.
I want to solve the problem.
Okay,
I want to make sure that school school
shootings never happened.
What can I do to actually make that
happen?
And what can I do while protecting the
second amendment?
Because I actually believe it's one of
those fundamental rights of Americans.
So while I was there,
I started speaking out and nobody cared,
like APP.
I would go to reporters and nobody
cared.
So I had to forcefully know,
like talk to reporters,
say,
hey look,
I'm a conservative.
Can I reach out?
And then I managed to get a Leland
Vitor,
a contact with Louis that are at Fox and
I want them Fox and I did an interview
and then Ben Shapiro psy and it blew
off.
But all the wild.
Yes.
That's the first time I remember seeing.
Yeah.
And all the while there's this extreme
opposition and the entire thing that
I've,
I've always had.
Sorry.
Well I just wanted to.
What do you,
because I know you,
you kind of mock the media the way I do
now on,
on twitter and just sort of what
mainstream media has become and that
they really activists and journalists
and that whole thing.
Um,
but were you shocked when you were going
up to them and going,
you know,
I'm a conservative or I want to defend
the second amendment,
but I'm a student from this school and
they're just blatantly ignoring you.
Or even.
I know this is minor,
but like I remember when a bunch of you
guys were all verified on twitter.
It was with instagram as well.
It took me like three months after
everyone else.
Yeah.
And I'm not saying that,
that it doesn't really mean it doesn't
matter in and of itself,
but it is,
it is a symptom of sort of the broader
situation going on here with tech
companies and media and all that.
Like were they flat out ignoring you?
You saw them interviewing people.
And then.
So here's here,
here's what occurred,
uh,
the main organizers of that,
that you can recruit a solid group of,
like the march for our live kids.
At this point they had solidified a
click and they wouldn't let anyone new
or with a different opposing view into
it.
So I said I had to take matters into my
own hand.
In addition,
we were in Tallahassee.
I realized that the mainstream media is
just doing this for clicks because can
we think about it when shooting occurs?
And the mainstream media loves it.
Like they get great coverage,
they get great amount of views,
they do.
Um,
I'll switch,
I'll talk to like notoriety in addition
after this.
But I saw that when someone,
there was a girl crying and Tallahassee
and the second she cried just,
she got sworn by reporters.
And I saw that they were just looking
for clicks and for headlines and I
realize that they're really,
they're not reading it for the right
reasons and they're not gonna listen to
a rational or irrational young kid like
me.
Okay.
So in addition,
I also realized that there was an
extreme amount of just.
People were just getting benefiting off
of this so much.
I'm so the shooting when you realized
that a lot of this occurred because the
shooter,
who I,
I try not to say his name ever because I
think that gives them to notarize them.
They,
they,
they would,
they would post.
So here's what time did.
So the video of the shooter were
basically says,
you know,
I'm going to be the next school shooter
of Twenty Eighteen,
I want 20 people.
And he basically says,
you're all going to see me on the news.
So.
And then Time magazine puts this video
up on Youtube.
It gets three point 6 million views.
The same thing with all the other
videos.
You know,
CNN talked about this exact clip and
basically just still showed it on air.
Yeah.
So the entire thing with the mainstream
media is doing is that they're
basically,
they're just benefiting off the
situation and what they don't realize
that they're perpetuating the issue and
making it worse.
That's why I think daily wire of Ben is
doing a great decision with not showing
their names and faces because it's an
ethical decision.
No,
I don't think government should impose
on,
on the mainstream media to not allow the
show their faces.
But I think it's an ethical and moral
decisions that people should be taking
up.
Yeah.
So just to be totally clear.
So after this shooting,
that was when Ben announced he's the
editor of wired,
they are no longer going to show their
name days after.
Yeah.
So okay.
So you started to see this,
this issue with the media that they're
ignoring people like you and they're
sort of making other people stars and
they're going for the clicks and all of
that.
What about,
you know,
I don't want to make this about people
per se,
but so that,
that little click of of kids that then
was all over the media and was getting
retweeted by every celebrity and all of
that.
Were you trying to reach out to them at
all and just have that discussion or was
it just very clear?
Oh No,
I still try to have that discussion.
You know,
when they first started speaking I said,
oh my God,
that's great.
Someone speaking out.
And originally when the movement started
speed,
when it started,
you know,
remember Cameron Caskey was on,
on the car shouting the movement wasn't
an Antiguan movement.
It was an anti school shooting.
And I said,
hey guys,
this is quickly.
I just,
I was like,
I gave him the morning guys,
it looks like you're moving through the
direction of an anti gun movement and I
don't think that's beneficial at all.
So here's my point of view.
I tried communicating and I,
and I tried speaking on and they really
didn't care in allowing me.
So I said,
okay,
I have to go solo.
And that's what I've been doing,
but I've,
I've always been open to discussion and
open debate.
I think it was one of the great things
that we're a country where you can have,
you know,
open discussion,
uh,
and just free expression of ideas.
That's why I think the Kanye thing is
somewhat great because regardless of
what you think of the person or
celebrity,
um,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not in favor of propping up
celebrities and their political opinion
simply because they're famous.
But you don't need a lot of political
expertise to say that I believe in free
expression,
free thought,
right?
That's,
that shouldn't be a really controversial
position to be,
to be staking out.
Alright.
So you mentioned cameron and you know,
I had them on the show a couple of weeks
ago.
He's going through a very interesting
evolution right now.
I suspect I can figure out where this is
going to end up,
which actually be much closer to your
position than the position that he sort
of at right now.
Because I just continually see that as
the evolution of things.
The more that he understands rights and
all of those things,
but I was happy to hear his thoughts and
all that and he sat down with me.
He sat down with Shapiro and I think
you'll continue to do that.
Um,
have you guys been able to make any
piece with some of this stuff or you
must at least be enjoying the fact that
somebody kind of coming around?
No,
I think.
I think Cam's a good guy.
I think that what we're seeing right now
is that he's matured.
I mean we've all made so and cam have
gone through like the same political
slash media experience so we can
understand each other.
What happened with came as like,
look,
we've all made mistakes.
We've all said stuff we don't want to,
but he's matured and I've also matured
a.
and what I see,
what I think is happening with Cam,
it's a natural progression of just
having logical thought instead of
emotions.
And I think logic and facts moves you
towards the political beliefs of being a
conservative.
Okay.
So all of this happens.
I think the,
the sort of rock bottom of this was that
CNN town hall.
That was terrible.
Yeah.
Just share your thoughts on that.
So here's what happened with the CNN
town hall.
So a lot of the kids that you saw there
were actually flown in on a private jet
from Tallahassee.
So already at the time of the town hall
there was a solidified group click of,
of the kids that you see now,
and they won't let anything until they
actually flew these kids on a private
jet from Tallahassee to the town hall.
And right there it was,
it was just simply,
they were just the,
it was an anti gun debate and they were
just villainizing Rubio in Dana lasts
for things that had nothing into their
control whatsoever.
It wasn't their fault.
And Marco Rubio was villainized to such
an extreme extent and he's one of the
best senators.
Uh,
so you've now connected with Rubio.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hate it because when people say that
politicians just don't care.
It's just so wrong.
I mean,
politicians,
they do care.
Um,
and you know,
he was one of the greatest supporters of
the school violence act that we got
passed,
um,
and you just helped push it and look,
these senators don't want this to occur.
Kenny was and just saying,
the politicians want this to happen.
It's just wrong.
Do you have any thoughts on what
actually happened that day in terms of
security or what should have happened or
should've or shouldn't have happened?
Because even now when you go back and
listen,
depending on where you're getting your
news from this,
it sounds,
you know,
they either step down or they didn't go
in or this or that or the other thing.
And it's like,
well,
what,
what should have happened in the ideal
world that you want to create in the
system that you want to create to
protect this,
these schools from not having this
happen again?
Um,
what,
what should it happen that day?
What we saw at my school was simply an
utterly just massive and competence and
failure of law enforcement.
You know,
the,
the.
So the shooter was flagged multiple
times by the school,
by the school administration.
They knew he had mental issues.
He was put into the promise program,
um,
and knew that this kid was a threat.
There were 76 times the police.
There were 76 times the police came to
his house,
the retreat,
FBI reports,
they knew that this kid was a threat and
the law enforcement was completely
incompetent at that level and they
didn't do absolutely anything.
Everyone knew this kid was an issue.
What happened at school was,
was just utter incompetence in addition.
So when he gets on campus,
okay,
you just make a straight beeline for the
freshman building and at the exact same
time we had a school resource officer
who,
who heard the gunfire and came and he
just hid in a corner while kids were
dying.
And then three unarmed individuals
rushed to save at three.
Oh,
three on our went to the building and
died trying to save kids.
What we should have had,
and this is why I pushed for it,
the only way to stop a shooter who is
active on campus is to have other people
who are armed.
The only way to stop,
it's not a cliche that you only way to
stop a bad guy with a gun is a good guy
with a gun,
and in addition to that,
there's the entire idea of a gun free
gun free zone.
It is utterly stupid.
It is just completely stupid.
All it's doing is enticing.
A target saying,
look,
you go here,
so here's,
here's what's the school?
The average response time from police
station to a school nationally is 15
minutes.
The average time a school shooting
happens is five minutes.
That means the shooter has 15 minutes to
do whatever he wants.
If the school is a gun free zone,
so here's what I'm saying,
at least allow teachers who have gone to
the proper training,
you know,
ex military ex law enforcement to be
armed because what that does is it sends
not only a message as a deterrent to a
shooter that says,
look,
this school is armed.
If you get in here,
your brains are going to be blown out.
It also says that that the school is in
a gun.
Free School is no longer a gun free
zone.
So I'm,
I'm with you partly on that.
So what I would,
maybe maybe you can explain this a
little bit further so I don't know that
I want guns in those classrooms even if
it's.
So here's the license usage.
I think there are 25 states where
teachers can be armed or not armed in
schools and all the hypotheticals that
are pronounced.
It's like,
you know what,
if a teacher shoots a student when
there's another like,
like what if there's a school shooter
and a teacher gets shot and there was a
gun on the floor.
What does a student do?
It's these hypotheticals don't happen.
20 five states where teachers are
already armed and it works.
So why not just have them have security
guards at specific?
So here's the thing,
I'm all for having security guards.
This entire issue is how do we best
manage our funds?
Insecure our schools.
The thing with law enforcement officers
that they cost a lot of money and
impoverished schools are ready need that
funding for materials.
And in addition,
it does not take a lot of training and a
lot of money to have a teacher to be
armed.
And this has already been proven to work
in an initiative when you have teachers
who are armed,
the shooter doesn't know who it,
if you,
if it's a law enforcement officer,
you can clearly see who it is.
So if you've one resource officer,
school resource officer who's armed,
the shooter comes and takes out the
school resource officer and then they're
free to do whatever,
but it's simply.
So here's the thing,
simply giving teachers to have the
opportunity has a massive effect because
it's up to their own will to do so they
have to go through training and they
have to.
It's a concealed carry.
So nobody knows they have them.
So as you said before,
you like facts and logic.
Okay?
Yeah.
Strictly facts.
Facts don't care about your feelings.
All right,
I got you.
That,
that,
that works.
When you've engaged some of your friends
and other students about these ideas.
I mean,
everyone watching this at this point
knows that so much of what's coming out
of the modern left is about feelings and
all of these things.
Do you have a sense that they understand
that young people,
at least the ones you're talking to
understand like,
what rights are,
what,
why,
why we should care about these things,
why free speech matters,
why the second amendment matters and
things of that nature.
So,
or does it all just sound good to them?
And there's a,
that's pretty much it.
It makes them feel good.
You know,
what they push and makes them feel good
by their emotions.
That makes sense.
So here's the thing,
I am very scared of lowering the age for
people to vote to be 15.
Like that scares me because the kids
that I know who are 15 know absolutely
nothing about politics.
I think I know like the kids from the
march for our lives better than I think
I know their own arguments better than
they know their own arguments.
Like I can argue for them better than
they can do.
So I strictly use facts only.
Um,
so when I make an argument with them,
I cannot really know what they're going
to do next.
So here's how I'll give you like a 10
minute or five minute recap.
Basically how I premise the second
amendment argument in America,
we have the right to bear arms in DC
versus Heller that rule that an
individual's right to arms.
It doesn't mean the militia,
the militia clause is different from the
individual,
right to bear arms.
That means that you personally have the
right to arm yourself.
Okay?
There are about 270 million guns in the
United States.
Fifty dollars million.
Those are air fifteens.
So we look at the guns sets are 33,000
annual gun deaths,
66 percent.
So two thirds are suicides.
So leaves us with 11,000
gun deaths a.
So we have to.
So in addition to put in parentheses,
there's a difference in a homicide and a
murder.
So homicide is,
is just a killing murders and unlawful
killing and gun stats.
A lot of them like to perverse this into
skew statistics.
So three percent of all gun deaths are
with rifles.
Okay?
And in that three percent,
68 percent of those are suicides.
So one percent of all gun that's are
actual murders are actually.
Sorry.
Yeah,
we're actually murders with rifles.
A 80 percent of all gun crime related
activity is with illegal firearms,
a most schools,
most shootings or with pistols.
So.
So march for life was five bullet
points.
One of them is like,
I don't like to talk about the CDC and
we should allow the CDC to research.
The issue with that is the CDC has
already proven to skew statistics and,
and to not actually provide good
research.
What research is it that they want?
So the CDC used to be able to do
research on gun violence prevention and
just figure out what's going on.
But it's been proven time and time again
that they screw their statistics.
So the Fargo and was like,
no,
we're not allowing you to penetrate a
false myth,
a myth.
So basically they stopped funding.
The next thing is that they want high
capacity magazines.
Uh,
there is no distinction there.
There was no difference.
That shows that high capacity magazines,
whatever that means,
can do more damage than simply having
more like clips.
I'm just having smaller,
having larger clips,
but less of them.
There's no distinction that actually
does more damage to the next thing that
they want to do is band semiauto rifles.
As I've said before,
only three percent of all gun deaths are
with rifles.
So banning them does absolutely nothing
addressing the issue in lowering a gun.
Violence is making sure that we have,
uh,
making sure that we have more people who
are armed because there's a direct
correlation,
not causation,
but correlation that when we increase
farm,
um,
ownership and concealed carry permits in
addition,
um,
violent crime goes down.
So the next thing that I'd like to
propose is what about Great Britain and
Australia?
So in Great Britain there was a,
there's a ban on guns and immediately
after violent crime spiked.
And in addition,
you have armed robberies increased.
So violent crime increased immediately
after and burglaries in Great Britain,
60 percent of them occur when the
individuals at home versus 13 percent of
the US.
So burglars have admitted that they do
this because they know that the person
will have like the purse or whatever,
and they won't,
there'll be on arm.
So violent crime spike.
The next thing is they say,
hey,
Kyla,
what about the Australian gun by
program?
So already in Australia when the program
was initiated,
there was already statistical zero,
uh,
for,
you know,
gun death and public mass public school
shootings.
Um,
so in addition,
when the buyback gets implemented there
already,
we're like the millions,
millions less guns in Australia than
there were now.
So the gun buyback grows in,
only one third of guns get taken.
And when we saw immediately after the
buyback was that violent crime spiked.
So here's just the basic argument,
there is not been one single occurrence
where gun control gets passed and,
and,
and gun deaths,
no gun homicides actually decreases at a
faster rate.
In Australia,
the gun,
the homicide rate was already decreasing
at a really good rate.
It gets passed gun control and the rate
stalls.
So it actually hurt an addition
immediately after it was passed to
violent crime rates go up.
And the national trend was going down,
so the gun buyback program was
completely ineffective,
did absolutely nothing,
and then it failed on such a huge level
in Australia that implementing it in the
US with 270 million guns simply won't
work.
All right,
so let's shift the discussion a little
bit to the NRA because that was the
other part of this that during the town
hall and the subsequent discussions
that it got very confused as to what the
NRA actually does.
What do they want to do?
What are their people who don't like
them,
think they do,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
so first off,
just give me your position on the NRA
general.
I think the NRA is a fantastic
organization that defends the rights,
the right to bear arms of individuals.
Thing with the NRA is that they really
don't have the money influence that
people say they do.
All they have is the social influence.
Republican senators know that the base
believes in the values that the NRA
promotes and defense.
And they understand that.
And if they go against the NRA,
they're going against their own
constituents.
The NRA does not have a big budget.
They really don't.
They're not like this super powerful
like that.
They directly control senators and
congressmen with their money.
They control with their ideals.
What the NRA does,
which is fantastic,
is it provides a check from the,
from the public,
not from the government for defending
our right to bear arms and it's
fantastic.
You know,
it helped I think with the case with
Mcdonald's for Chicago that helped
bolster a second amendment rights for
individuals.
I mean,
and the NRA does just does a great job.
They're NRA Ila program,
which is actually the legislative branch
on defending the second amendment,
does a fantastic job.
I think right now they're taking a case
against raising the age from 18 to 21.
There was right for the shooting of Rick
Scott signed into law in Florida,
raising the age to buy,
I think a firearm or rifle now.
So before,
before,
uh,
you couldn't buy a handgun if you're
under 21,
but you could buy a rifle because
handguns were used in violent crimes.
Whether I think that's right or not,
that's a separate discussion.
But he raised the age from 18,
21 to buy a rifle and directly the NRA
was like,
this is unconstitutional.
Boom.
We put it in the lawsuit just to address
that.
Eighteen to 21 age.
Uh,
there is absolutely no evidence that
raising the age does absolutely.
Does,
does anything to,
uh,
to lower,
um,
gun homicide whatsoever.
So what do you think about the certain
set of people that think that if we
could just have all of the right laws or
if we could just manage everything
properly,
that everything would be fine because he
doesn't take into fingers.
We have a ball.
All the laws that we need already on the
books as thing,
as the enforcement doesn't work.
So I'll just make a tangent.
I'll get back to here.
I think it is utterly hypocritical that
the left hates trump and they,
that he's in power,
but then they're saying we have to trust
they cover more.
So if you think the government,
if you think trump is literally Hitler,
why are you giving away your right to
bear arms to this tyrannical government?
Um,
it was the question again.
Well,
just that there's a certain set of
people that think if we,
I got you.
So we already have the,
the laws on the books,
you know,
just the enforcement and the enforcement
of what needs to occur.
Like the Lautenberg amendment means that
domain,
it says that domestic abusers cannot
have a firearm that's already on the
books.
It just needs to be enforced.
There's the issue with um,
you know,
the nics background check program where
they say we need more time to,
to evaluate and give you back your
background check in order to buy a
weapon.
The issue is the government doesn't need
more time,
it just needs more of the records.
So the reason why the Texas oil and
shooting occurred was because I think it
was some military brands where there was
someone where he,
he committed a violation and by law they
sh the heat.
They should have transferred that over
to the database and there,
if we wouldn't have been able to buy a
weapon,
but the records weren't transferred.
He was able to buy a weapon and he shot
up the church.
So the government just needs to get all
the records and do their job.
Same thing with red flag laws,
um,
and people like to talk about this.
This is a little bit more of the
trickier areas of this,
but red flag laws basically say that
someone can flag you and then you get
reviewed and then you can get your gun
taken away.
And a lot of people also like.
So the issue with red flag gun laws is
that it's all about government
enforcement and,
and that's,
that's the issue.
And there's also the big issue where
people like to talk about mental health
and they say you're mentally ill,
people shouldn't be able to acquire
weapon.
So I have talked to countless
individuals about this and I should ask
Peterson but I forgot to.
The question is how do you determine
when someone is mentally ill enough and
hits the threshold so they cannot have a
weapon and nobody knows.
And in addition to things with the
shooter at my school looking
retroactively,
we can say this kid was mentally insane,
but I don't know if a court would
adjudicate that.
He would actually be mentally insane by
by law,
therefore taking his gun away.
Yeah.
So is the inherent problem here.
Do you think that you cannot manage all
of these things?
You can do the best you can to have some
sensible laws around them and defend our
right to bear arms and all of that and
make sure schools are taken care of,
but that generally speaking,
yes,
there's a sort of sliding scale
psychologically,
but also that the people that want to do
bad,
we'll find ways to do bad.
They're not the ones that are walking
out and looking at a building and it
says,
oh no guns here,
so not going to walk in with a gun.
Criminals will act like criminals no
matter what,
but the good thing is that our laws are
working.
I mean,
I think it's violent crime or some rate
from the 1998 to 2010 has decreased by
50 percent and and pub in schools are
safer now than they were 20 years ago.
Like school shooting rates are declining
and homicide,
right?
Gun homicide rates are declining in the
homicide rates are declining.
So we're becoming a more peaceful nation
and a lot of that has to do with having
more gun owners and to having more
concealed carry permit owners because
those people,
when when there's a shooting,
those people are the first responders.
I think it's wrong to say that.
Oh well we'll just let the police arrive
after the crime has been committed.
No,
you need people there immediately to
stop the shooter.
That's why I'm all for having teachers
and arm school officers at schools to
immediately take down the shooter.
All right,
so let's shift.
I mean,
I don't think we're going to fully get
away from guns here,
but let's shift a little bit.
Okay.
What is it like to be a 17 year old
right now that's in the mix of this?
That's now a public person.
Crazy.
Yeah.
To just be part of this,
this oddly unique time where it feels
like the adults have lost the plot and
it's got to be very hard for you to find
people that kind of makes sense.
I think you've been able to find a
couple of them,
but just to be 17 in this very odd
political cultural time.
It's insane.
Like what does it feel unique to you?
I know you haven't lived through this
before,
but like
they don't know how to judge it.
All I know is that I'm an adult now and
I have to act like an adult,
whether whether I'm 17 or 18,
I have committed like commitments that I
make.
I have to go through with them and I've
just.
My immaturity,
I was forced to become mature.
Like I can no longer play video games
and waste time.
There's things that I have to do but
I've just been so blessed to find a
solid group of people who actually care
about me and want the best for me.
Like,
like Ben and Charlie Guy,
Benson.
People who have just reached out to me
and I'm just selflessly helped me
navigate this political minefield.
But it's crazy [inaudible] like all the
people that I looked up to like two
years ago and like watch their videos,
like not gonna snack,
trying to like boost your ego here.
But I used to,
I would watch her show,
please continue,
but yeah,
it's awesome that now I can reach out
for their expertise.
The thing with me is that I always like
to start with,
look,
I don't know anything and I'm always
looking to get more information to know
more.
Like today I had a call with a gun
expert.
I'm on the way here and it's like,
what more can I learn in order to be
like fully fluent and,
and knowledgeable about the subject that
I'm talking about and there are a bunch
of stuff that I don't know about and I'm
constantly trying to learn.
So when you see a guy,
and again I don't like making this about
people rather than ideas,
but when you see a guy like David Hogg
out there and he clearly is taking just
the progressive line on this and he
seems more to me to be sort of a
progressive activists than sort of a,
a fair arbiter of what's going on here.
Um,
that's gotta be frustrating for you that
he's so public about this.
I suppose so.
Well that you obviously probably
disagree with him on on 100 percent of
the policy parts.
This is true.
Yeah.
I don't want to make it about the
personal part,
but that he's thought of as sort of a
media hero and you're kind of the black
sheep of this group.
I mean maybe not to the,
to the Shapiros and me and whoever else.
Yeah.
So here's what I say.
There is no issue that kids are on
television.
The issue is is that when someone is
spouting policy that they are no longer
a child,
they are pushing policy and they should
be treated as every adult does such when
you say something outrageous,
you should be called out on that.
Remember there's a segment with you.
It was on cnn where he said something
completely outlandish a and there was no
blowback Solo.
Well,
I think it was that the line Marco Rubio
wants to kill kids or something.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So what I say is when I'm pushing policy
and I say thanks to the police,
like tell me that I'm saying something
stupid and pushed me back on that.
The thing is with me that look when I'm
on TV,
I'm not talking as a child and pushing
policy,
right.
And I expect there to be pushed back.
I don't think you can say whatever you
want like and in addition,
I think that having debate is great.
So like I love,
I love going on piers Morgan and having
a debate with that was great and I think
we have to.
I hate this thing where like we're,
we're one second you're spouting policy,
but then you rushed back to the Dust
Shield of Oh,
I'm a child,
but we have to take my opinion seriously
because the second I said I'm an adult,
so just,
just this isn't,
this isn't fair.
And what I saw,
I think one of the reasons why I grew to
such publicity was because I was saying
the things that adults weren't able to
say.
Like I was able to say things that Ben
Shapiro or you or Charlie Kirk or the
right wasn't able to say because I'm a
kid and I don't think that's fair.
Because I think that when you're
spouting policy,
you are no longer a child.
You're an adult,
what do you make of what's going on with
the right generally because you ran the
turning point.
Was that the high school event that I
did?
I've done so many scholarships on you.
Okay.
So you did the high school leadership
summit in DC and I spoke there.
This is a couple of months ago and you
had a great lineup of speakers and Peter
till is there and you had big,
big time politicians and,
and first off,
I mean that was the first time we met
and I was like,
Holy Shit.
We just debate about abortion.
Abortion.
Exactly.
So that's my point.
So first of all,
you,
you ran this whole thing.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're still in high school,
right?
We're going to talk a little bit about
where you want to go to college and all
that,
but you ran an incredible event with
major prime time people and,
and it was,
it was jam packed and it was a diverse
in terms of ideas.
So we get into a private debate about
abortion,
but you brought me there.
Uh,
and I went up there.
Thanks.
But I,
I went up there and I talked about my
differences with this group I talked
about and the kids were respectful and I
talked about gay marriage and abortion
and death penalty in a couple of other
things that generally these young
conservatives are not for.
I think gay marriage there pretty much
for.
I hope that the ship has sailed on that
one actually.
I'm pretty sure I got a huge ovation on
that.
Um,
but it is just clear to me that there
has been a realignment on the right
where there is exactly what you're
talking about.
Can we just say that Lindsey Graham?
Two point.
Oh is fantastic.
No,
the guy.
It's unbelievable that,
I mean,
just that one thing with the tie the
daily caller.
Right.
So I think the rightest finally
realizing that youth,
um,
and like energizing the youth and
instilling the next future of
conservative leaders is extremely
important.
And we saw that with the high school
leadership summit.
We had some of the biggest names speak
like Nikki Haley.
That's advice we'd like turning jeff
sessions we had so people.
And every week we had Mark Meadows.
We had Steve scully's,
we had,
we had prager u and it was just,
it was fantastic to see the right.
Just understand that these are the
leaders of tomorrow,
let's inform them,
but in addition,
turning point is such a great
organization.
It's free speech,
free markets and capitalism.
Those are the three legs.
Uh,
and what we saw with turning point is
such a,
it's such a great organization because
we were,
we brought people who I have
disagreements with to speak there.
Mark Cuban spoke,
got a couple standing ovations,
had a debate with Charlie and people
loved it.
So we're all open having free discussion
and debate.
Like we're,
we're,
we're working on sassal shooting action
summit,
December 19,
20 seconds,
shameless plug.
And we're,
we're looking like how can we get the
most diverse group of people to speak?
Like I'm thinking about something from
the intellectual dark web to speak
there.
I think it's great if we can get Alan
Dershowitz just how can we get diversity
of thought?
So why is it that these new right or
whatever you want to call it,
young conservative group,
whatever it is.
Why is it that you guys are able to do
this and I see virtually none of this
on your counterparts on the left.
That's not true.
I mean the left has organize and
mobilize youth dish right now.
Well,
I mean,
no,
but I'm talking about diversity of
thought.
Like where are they bringing a mildly
disagree with.
I'm not talking about scary
conservatives.
I'm talking about old school liberals
were.
Where are they inviting them to just
have an interesting conversation.
Yes.
Just so dead set on political
correctness and saying everything to not
offend anyone with the slightest micro
micro micro aggression that is just.
You can't live in that world and and
tall like logical liberals like yourself
are moving
to the right.
These subtle little injections of
pleasantry yeah,
that's nice.
Are moving people to the
right and conservatives are like,
come here,
my.
He is.
My political refugees were embracing
you.
Yeah.
So.
Okay.
So when I hear people will say,
Ruben,
the conservatives are just using you.
You go to turning point.
They were just using you.
You're not just using Mikael.
No,
I mean,
yeah,
no,
but really,
I mean what I've seen is intellectual
flexibility there and it's even when
I've had been in here and we've done
this conversation repeatedly now about
gay marriage,
I just firmly believe that as time goes
on I can shift him.
I,
there's something that's sort of
insulting about it to me.
When people say that to me because I'm
confident,
I'm confident enough in my,
he's going to take you on abortion.
I really think that like in a few years
you'll be with us on a board
mean maybe,
but you know what?
That would be a trade off,
right?
Like if,
if,
if ultimately I always described myself
as begrudgingly
of of homosexuality.
While I don't,
I don't,
I don't have a strong opinion on it
because I haven't thought about it
enough.
By his religious standpoint.
It makes sense,
but from the government standpoint,
it also makes total sense.
Well,
that's why I'm completely fine with him.
It's like you want to have your
religious.
I have to respect that,
but if you are trying to legislate,
the great thing with the right is that
we're open to this diversity of thought.
Just say whatever you want,
let's talk about it and let's get to the
right rational viewpoint.
Like I've,
I've always been about the bait because
it brings people,
it's all about logic and it brings
people to the right end result.
So when I'm on tour with Peterson,
a w,
the question that I think both of us get
asked more than anything else is,
what are the best techniques to wake
people up out of this sort of postmodern
identity,
politics,
progressive group.
Think as a young person in the midst of
this,
what would you say are some techniques
you've been able to use?
Because it can't just be about drubbing
them with facts,
right?
I mean,
the left is doing a fantastic job with.
They're just craziness and pushing
people to the right.
So it's just sort of doing it on
himself.
Um,
well what we saw right now with canyon
and in addition,
it's just,
he was simply saying,
freedom of expression,
freedom of thought.
I support the president.
Our president has to be the freshest,
the flies thoughts.
I'm just pushing people to diversity of
thought and freedom of expression to
think whatever you want you shouldn't
have.
You shouldn't be held down by your skin
color or your race or your sexuality.
Like none of this matters.
You should be able to think what you
want and be able to say it without being
tied down by you know,
your identity.
Yeah.
How do you make sure that you don't get
burned out?
Because I think I remember the first
communication we ever had.
I think when either you followed me or I
followed you on twitter.
I just sent you a quick one line note
and I was just like,
just don't get burned out because I saw
you just.
You were in the fight everyday.
You were,
you were owning,
owning the libs and all that.
Which by the way,
you know,
you mentioned that Nikki Haley was at
your summit and she went,
she went to to,
you know,
in effect,
what is a,
a lot of trump people right at this,
at this event you put on.
She goes there and she says,
you know,
don't make this about just owning the
libs and she got applause for it and I,
I hit that same point I think the next
day because I think if you guys do
exactly what you just laid out,
just kind of stand there.
It would be cool and be decent.
You'll,
you will welcome a lot of them.
Well,
I think,
I honestly believe that decency wins.
Can we just take a second and that Nikki
Haley is fantastic and I,
I,
I kind of cried for like a week ever
since.
What do you think that this is perhaps a
paving the road for her running at some
point?
I don't know.
There's so many 40 chests,
like theories.
I just know I just,
I know that she's just been doing a
fantastic job and she's just one of the
best.
I know Nikki Haley.
Ben Shapiro.
Twenty 24.
Yeah,
I mean I'd probably have to be press
secretary at that point.
Yeah,
that would work for like one horrific
week and then.
No,
that'd be fine.
I should do.
All right.
So gimme,
Gimme some of the techniques when you
see that it can't just be about standing
still and,
and facts if you're,
if you're in a conversation with a young
person that's really just bought into
all of this,
what are some of the techniques you
used?
Have you been successful?
I suspect that you sometimes.
Yeah,
I think I have.
The first thing you
have to realize is that is this person
looking cap and open discussion and
actually wants.
Sorry about that.
Talking a lot these days.
It's all right.
I know it's too much or,
or actually wants to develop their point
of view.
If they do,
you have to treat it with decency and
respect and not call them an idiot or
something.
You have to treat them like a,
like a good human being should,
um,
and then just have a rational
conversation with them and see where
they're coming from.
A and a lot of times I can immediately
know what they're going to respond to me
like just straight off the bat,
I know what they're gonna respond to me
and I hit them with,
with an initial,
here's what you're gonna say,
here's the reason.
And they're just shocked.
But then do you get them around?
I mean do,
do you find because it really,
it's like sort of deprogramming somebody
out of this and I've had some success at
it.
Right.
And a lot of them have watched my show
now.
So yeah,
I mean when I first heard speaking out,
kids would come up to me in school and
two things they would say it'd be like,
Kyla,
I'm a conservative.
So,
so the thing about school is really
interesting.
I wouldn't get stare downs and like
people would like try to beat me up so
people would like send me like,
hey kyle,
watch out.
So and so trying to beat you up.
I was like,
all right man,
go for it.
Okay.
Um,
and people would give me stare downs and
there was such villainization of being
conservative being second amendment
supporter.
When I spoke up I kind of opened the
crack for people to say,
Oh,
I agree with him.
People would walk up to me and like
caught up like,
Kyle,
thank you so much for doing.
I'm just scared to speak out.
And in addition people say,
Kyle,
I thought I was pro gun control and you
spoke and I listened to you and then I
did some more research and I agree with
you.
So that was great to see it.
And like that's just,
that's all I'm here for.
So to have people,
you know,
understand conservatism and understand
the second amendment,
it's got to be pretty weird that you
guys are still in high school,
right?
Like now you're your celebrities in the
most strange sense of celebrity you are
and your role still in high school
together.
What is that like?
I mean,
at the end of the day we have to
remember that we're kids and I will
explain it to you guys.
Don't think I'm hypocritical.
Um,
when you're on TV and you're spouting
politics during adult but in your
private life you were a kid and we
cannot forget that.
So let's say,
you know,
when someone,
some kid on the left does something
stupid.
It's at the end day,
they're a kid and we have to address it
as such,
um,
but,
but it's,
it's been a crazy world when and I
think,
thank God I found a solid group of
people who want the best for me that I
can reach out,
you know,
just not for policy,
but it's also like personal advice.
Like I,
I,
uh,
I asked Ben,
Hey,
how do you think I should approach
college apps and some conservative,
you know,
and he helped me out and it's just,
it's so great to be able to reach out to
people and have them,
you know,
give you advice from like 20 years older
than me and given me that advice that
they had to go through the,
what was that great tweet?
So you're like number one in your class,
right?
Not like number one.
You are number one,
you're correct.
There was some tweet that you had about
that,
that awesome.
Yeah.
What was that
number one?
Yeah.
Um,
and people got so angry,
so angry and they're like,
we're going to boycott graduation.
So I was like,
Yay.
More cake.
It was great.
And then,
you know,
the next step,
what was the reason they wanted to
boycott because I was number one,
so then the semester updated and then I
was still number one.
So I posted another tweet about that and
then also blew up and I was like,
we're going to get Ben Shapiro to come.
Data Lash is gonna come.
It's gonna be fantastic.
Chris Cox was like,
yeah,
I'm going to be there.
Why would they want.
I mean,
is that really how sort of polarizing
Lee crazy this has got at a high school
level that just because they don't like.
I mean you're your number one not by,
by being more deemed.
No until your number one out of clearly
a lot of hard work and smarts and all
that.
You'd think that there would be certain
respect for that in some alternative.
It's sad that we have,
we are no longer able to be friends with
people like it's sad that people on the
left think so people on the left think
that you're a Republican,
therefore you're evil and that sad that
you're not allowed to be friends with
people who have different political
viewpoints and you're like,
my best friend is a liberal and I
actually brought him to the turning
point event and after it was like,
you know,
Kyle,
some awesome people.
And I was like,
yeah,
I told you.
He still liberal.
He's an old school.
That's cool.
These probably we're getting there.
You and him both.
All right,
so wait,
let's talk a little bit about college.
So you're,
you're doing a great job in high school.
Clearly now you've got a public profile.
Grades are great.
Seemingly you could get in to wherever
you want to go and do it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So do you really think that that will
play a role in,
in the schools that you're able to get
into?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's sad to say,
but,
but there is a bias against
conservative,
especially like the top tier schools.
Like right now I'm looking to apply to
ivy's.
It'd be great to get into Harvard or
Columbia.
I really think a man,
you'd be the reckoning of those places.
I really think it'd be awesome.
I really think that.
I think it's really important to be
accredited.
Um,
you know,
I might,
I'm thinking about Georgetown or Gw to
work on the hill.
I think that's great.
Um,
but yeah,
like I really,
I really don't know what's next for me.
I really don't go to college.
I'm definitely going to stay with
turning point.
It's a great organization.
I'm still going to be conservative.
Don't worry.
I'm not going to change to change.
People don't go the other way,
right?
You're not going to suddenly grow up and
be like,
no,
no.
I'll go to the feelings.
Things that,
that usually does,
that won't happen.
Yeah.
But all right,
so you want to go to school,
but you.
So you really do think that your,
your politics could affect I guess.
Well,
what happened with David Hogg Right?
He didn't get into to all,
I don't know what his grades are,
but like he didn't get into a whole
bunch of schools.
Right.
I mean there've been rumors that he got
into Harvard.
Northeastern,
it wouldn't surprise me.
Yeah.
And what do you want to study?
You have any idea?
It's either business or law.
I really don't know yet.
I just,
you know,
I,
I've always liked business and I think
law is just absolutely phenomenal.
Really don't know yet.
Uh,
but you know,
it's going to be great to be on a
college campus where everyone is just
really liberal.
That'll be fun.
It's sort of weird and I guess this
shows a little bit about the way the
college experience is going,
but in a bizarre way,
just knowing you from the little bit
that I know you,
it's like in a way it's almost like you
don't have to go to college like you.
Well,
I'm not saying you shouldn't and I think
there's all sorts of social reasons that
somebody should go and you can,
you know,
you learn in all sorts of other ways
that aren't necessarily academic,
but it's like clearly you've got the
academic thing down and can keep
learning that way.
So it's,
you know,
it's bizarre that people spend,
20 grand a year to go to college when no
one thing is we're surrounded by a lot
of great minds is what I'm saying.
I'm with you.
But the issue with colleges that you're
basically paying to get,
you're so brainwashed with stupidity and
that's suck part because there were
actual,
like great things to learn in college.
Just not like lesbian dance theory that
says that a lot.
Some of these classes are just useless
and you know,
and just,
it's just straight up complete
stupidity.
A lot of the stuff that they're teaching
there.
So what do you make of how this seems to
be a through line through education and
I mean high school education,
college education.
Clearly the media,
like all of this sort of brainwashing
stuff that you're talking about.
It's always going against people like
you and I see you on twitter,
you take down cnn all the time,
you take down main street all the time.
People know my thoughts on this.
It's like I just wish like to me,
if these,
we just address that twitter,
just twitter's for fond and we have to
stop taking twitter,
associate your bio.
Your bio is perfect.
Twitter is not real life.
It's not real life but pete.
But the weird thing about that is it's
starting to leak into real life.
I did a direct message like a year and a
half ago or so about how online culture
is becoming mainstream culture and I
think that that really is what's
happening here.
Twitter is not real life but it's
starting to like leak out into
everyone's conversation.
So Fox News and CNN and MSNBC or
basically trump's twitter,
like twitter is like,
you know,
like have you seen shows where they
basically read random replies to
messages.
It's like John Smith,
three point seven,
four for this like that.
So
stupid.
But the biggest thing that we're seeing
right now is,
is a cultural shift with the youth,
like memes,
memes have so much power in our lives
matter.
Memes,
one,
a lot of memes helped so much for the
trumps 2016 campaign with it really did.
Um,
and social media has a huge influence on
our beliefs and our actions and that's
why it is so scary to see censorship of
Conservatives online because that is
basically like twitter is basically the
new version of you just like yelling
into a crowd and that's basically like
the main form of everyone's
communication and shutting that down.
It's like heavily restricting,
you know,
I haven't developed my full opinion on
this,
but it seems as such restricting this
restricts your,
like really restricts your First
Amendment,
right?
Yeah.
So this is the whole issue about whether
they're publishers or platforms.
Yeah.
Big issue.
I don't know if I'm saying this right,
but I think one of the things is if
there are certain if there or if they're
a published further than like they have
a lot of legal liability.
If they're a platform,
then every everyone should say whatever
they want,
but that's not the case,
so just pick one and they're just
completely censoring conservatives.
Like I know prager u gets like their
videos demonetize so much and have your
videos got demonetized?
They probably,
yeah.
Well now now it's gotten a little bit
better,
but our video is just don't go out to
feeds anymore.
I went on that rhythm.
Yeah,
that crazy rampage I went on where I
just started retweeting real people.
I only did it with real people with real
names saying they'd been unsubscribed
and they're getting hundreds and
sometimes thousands of retweets and I'm
tagging youtube and they just ignore me
and it's like,
come on guys.
I mean you to play the game a little
bit.
Both facebook and twitter all have
proven biases.
Proven.
Yeah.
How worried are a.
So it's really interesting to me because
you never.
You didn't grow up in a time when there
was some sort of trustworthy,
seemingly trustworthy level of the
media.
Like CNN was not always this.
The reason I don't even know if you know
this,
but the the reason I think that so many
people like me that are older than you
attack cnn the most is cassina and used
to be decent like msnbc saying,
we lean left Fox and CNN saying that,
and it's like,
no,
you're not.
We know exactly what you're doing and
that's why I always tax CNN because it's
like you guys have actually become the
worst.
The ratings are like the lowest.
It's like a block of read CNN.
Yeah.
So here's what I think.
I think that a lot of young people and
like an average Americans do not trust
the media anymore and they have sought
out individuals instead.
So they trusted individuals.
So they look to you,
they look to Ben,
they look to a Guy Benson,
Charlie Kirk for,
for their news because they trust the
individual.
Right.
Do you see a great risk in that too?
Because I'm worried about that.
I also put.
But the thing is with that is that you
have absolute liability for what you
say.
You know,
CNN can whip something up or you know,
but when,
when an individual like tweets
something,
it's on like they're responsible for
their actions.
Yeah.
So one of the things I've been saying
lately is that I'm actually in a bizarre
way less interested in politics now than
I've ever been,
but I'm interested in what,
you referenced it a little while ago,
this culture thing.
I mean culture,
where does it cultures,
politics is downstream from culture.
Yeah.
That's so true.
So do you see that really as a sort of
the future of all this,
that it's not going to be about all of
the little machinations of politics,
it's just going to be about.
I mean this,
I guess this is the strength of trump.
Well,
where you'd argue it's either the
strength or the,
the worst
part of trump.
I suppose that's a cultural thing.
Not necessarily a political thing.
No,
I mean there,
there are pros and cons to that,
but we just have to play by the rules
that are set by society and these are
the rules.
These are rules that culture has a
massive impact on society and whether I
like it or not,
that Kanye,
Kanye speaking out.
First of all,
I think it's great to be speaking out to
the First Amendment right.
I don't think we should be propping up
opinions by celebrities,
siblings,
because they're famous.
You have to show that you are informed
on the subject and that's that.
But it doesn't take a political genius
to say that I believe in our second
amendment and our first amendment that
doesn't take but Taylor swift doing like
a 7,000
page essay,
you know,
that makes absolutely no sense and
contradicts itself written by like a
liberal,
you know,
a worker on the hill.
That's what I was disappointed in that
just because I have no particular
feelings about her when I don't care.
I honestly don't think I could name one
song or whatever,
but it's just like the fact that she
stayed out of politics.
I liked,
I was like,
oh,
whatever she's doing or whatever.
Her handlers are saying to her,
I kinda like it.
And then she got in on this and it's
like,
I don't care which way she was going to
break.
I was just like,
ah,
this is not what we need.
Yeah,
I mean,
Taylor swift effect president is like
down Marsha Blackburn love.
So thanks Taylor swift.
No,
but,
but what we saw right now by the left is
that they are losing their stranglehold
on culture and that is very frightening
for them.
And we saw that with Connie and Connie
started speaking out.
I gave my speech about this and they
started off with mob tactics that didn't
work.
Uh,
emotional appeal.
The TMZ guy was basically begging him
like,
Kanye,
please men take,
take off your hat,
man.
It hurts me emotionally.
It was like,
no,
it's my first semester.
I'm not taking it off.
And then we saw just blatant racism,
viola character,
assassinations and disgusting.
You wouldn't know that.
That is.
How does that fly?
He wouldn't bow down to the mob.
Absolutely wouldn't be,
but no,
they're losing their stranglehold on
culture.
And whether I like that we are putting
so much emphasis on cultural icon.
Those are the rules.
The rules say that on twitter,
a lot of rules,
but this is,
this is,
this is the reality that we're living in
and we have to understand that and
what's happening with Kanye is a real
shift,
especially for African Americans and
people who were like in Little Tinos.
They're basically saying,
I don't know why this controversial.
Blackstone have to be Democrats.
You don't own me.
That's all.
Basically,
it's all he sang and he has created such
like a pivotal moment that says,
you're,
you don't,
you're stranglehold doesn't affect me
because I know in Hollywood,
like the second you say something like,
I remember someone said,
Ben Shapiro is a nice guy.
His career was destroyed.
Yeah.
Mark Duplass,
who's a friend of mine who's been on
this show and he had to issue an apology
and it's like,
you know,
oddly.
Whereas the ID people,
people came to his defense at first
basically saying,
you know,
you should be allowed to say that.
Yeah.
And then unfortunately he issued and
black,
especially young blacks are saying,
look,
they look up to Kanye west and the
millions look up to him and they say,
this individual,
why does this individual think this way?
And even more so he didn't bow down to
the mob,
which is fantastic.
And we're seeing a real shift.
I don't know the 38 percent number.
We're 38 percent African American
approval over trump.
I don't know if that's necessarily true.
All I know is that there was a three
percent jump from there was in August.
The black approval rating of trump was
three percent.
One of the last latest polls that I know
month or so ago was 10 percent.
So there's a big jump in,
you know,
we're seeing that so many young African
Americans are so energized.
Like I know turning point is doing a
black leadership summit like a week in
the White House.
We're going to get just 400 African
American young individuals to be able to
speak their since table listen.
And to see that the left is losing their
stranglehold on culture.
And it is scary for them because that is
the one thing that they have left.
All right,
I got two more for you.
All right.
You are you in the prediction game at
all?
What do you think's going to happen in
these midterms?
We've got coming up.
So what I've been hearing is that
Republicans or lose it in the house and
gain in the Senate.
Uh,
I love how your work has,
is that we're going to win back the
executive.
These midterms are confused about but
looks the cabinet effect is real.
Like this was like the,
all the left had to do was sit down,
be quiet,
be civil plaintiffs to like,
no,
this is,
we're not going to allow this.
Okay.
And they hit themselves in the foot with
the club and then there started crying.
And then the same thing with Kanye.
That was great.
So the cabinet really amped up and
energized the conservative base and even
more so it finally gave the conservative
like the conservatives a backbone,
like Lindsey Graham,
Lindsey Graham.
Two point.
Oh.
Or is this skype in?
I love it.
And like bill cassidy.
But,
but here's the peers of the interesting
thing.
Women were the most angered by all of
this.
Before the cabinet in August,
it was like a 35 point seven percent
approval of trump after it was a 40
point seven.
And then in August I'm the Democrats at
a 12 point lead over republicans in a
voter doozy.
Asm.
Now it's 64 percent republican,
65 Democrats.
So we are neck and neck and they said
it's all thanks to the Democrat.
Yeah,
I mean my gut.
As long as you're doing predictions
here,
I actually think the Republicans that
are do well in both the house and the
Senate.
I really hope so.
But I do think so because I agree.
I think this mob mentality and watching
these videos of Antifa and Portland and
Hillary saying we can't be civil and
Eric holder saying below them and it's
like,
man,
if you stand for due process and civil
society and all of those things,
that thing needs to burn it.
It kind of sucks.
But it's like that.
That set of ideas
thinks the left just completely
disregards the constitution.
The constitution was written and in the
amendment,
Bill of rights was forced by anti
federalists to make sure that the
government cannot become tyrannical and
abuse its power,
and this is so important.
It's protecting the rights of the
individuals in these rights.
Why?
Why do we not all agree on them?
Why is it wrong to believe nude process?
Why is it wrong to say,
I believe that individuals should have
the right to defend themselves and also
defend against the tyranny of a possible
government.
Look,
second man was basically Britain because
the founders had just fought against
Great Britain and they had seen how a
turntable government quickly become.
So one more thing I didn't know.
The first thing tyrannical government
stay was they take away the weapons of
the civilians.
So it's Nazi Germany.
We saw this in China,
we saw this in in Cambodia.
That's the first thing they do,
and the individual right to bear arms is
every individual is not related to the
militia clause.
So it's basically saying every
individual has the right to protect
themselves and even more so it's.
It's necessary for the protection of a
free state.
All right,
one more for you.
Hit me with you.
Don't play video games as much because
you don't have time.
What do you do for fun,
man?
What's fun?
I used to sites.
Twitter.
You can't just tell me twitter.
I know you have to put it on twitter but
it can't just be twitter.
What are you doing for fun?
So with me,
I used to play a lot of video games.
What kind of games?
So here's,
here's my progression.
I haven't said this,
but this is like a scoop tanks.
Okay.
Advent moved to to,
to a rocket league.
Okay.
It's sockets.
Terrible game.
It's boring.
Then it moved to,
I played overwatch Paladins.
I played pub g and I played for night
and four nine.
This was when the shooting occurred and
I just stopped dead in my tracks because
it was just,
it's a waste of time and I see my
younger brothers who were addicted to
the game and it's just sad to see that
this is the state of our youth,
that they're just completely addicted to
technology.
Like,
I'm sure if I have kids.
Okay.
They're not saying a phone till they're
12.
You didn't ever.
They do call me or nine slash 11.
No video games or reading a book.
I don't care.
So what do you do for fun?
You just told me what you used to do.
Come on.
You must be having fun somewhere.
You're having fun sometimes.
Wow.
I got you.
Yeah man did you're,
you are having fun with this.
I have some of them,
um,
of the
remaining friends that I have which are
really solid friends on weekends we hang
out,
we go watch movies and stuff like that.
In addition,
I,
I just think it's great.
One of the greatest things for me for
having funders,
just simply talking to like minded kids,
like young individuals at these turning
point events that we run and it's great
and like meeting with pushing policy and
stuff like that.
It's just fantastic.
One of the greatest feelings ever was
like passing the Stop School Violence
Act and fixing nick's like the stops go.
Ransack appropriated funds
$2,000,000,000
in funds for the production of schools
like hardening schools,
metal detectors.
I'm making better communication between
law enforcement,
training,
law enforcement teachers and students.
In addition,
there was a clause that said none of
this money will be used for firearm or
firearm trainings.
So this was like the greatest win for
the left and they still hated the bill
and like the march for life,
kids hated it.
But no,
I mean I'm really dead set on making
sure that school shootings are a thing
of the past.
They never happened again.
Uh,
and you love what you do and just like,
just learning about the second amendment
and just like being more knowledgeable
and having these debates and discussions
are just like they really make my day.
Well,
I think it goes without saying.
I mean,
I think you have an absurdly bright
future.
Thank you.
You're going to run for president or
something?
Probably not for,
but you left a little window.
No,
I mean,
I literally do navy.
There's a thing,
um,
for politics and like the hill in the
future.
Right now I'm just dead set on going to
college,
getting my degree,
learning,
staying the political sphere.
But uh,
you know,
who knows,
I'm definitely supporting Nikki.
Haley's Shapiro Twenty 24.
All right.
You see people there is hope for the
future.
For more on Kyle,
follow him on twitter at Kyle
[inaudible].